welcome to this video Kakarot oh the sky
don't know him okay um somewhat
something else here not to play the NIMS
oh all the time let's go for a king's
indian what is he doing yeah this line
it's a good line recommended that right
in my order video series just going to
be quick em for once not sure that was
so great okay can probably play that go
Bishop d7 here hmm okay so he's castling
short boom okay maybe I can prepare at
five he's allowing that that's not so
common that that white allows his Queen
side freeze him can do this Oh f1 I have
four maybe I did not really place
correctly for that I mean F was kind of
the only idea that he has left him with
with with the queenside freeze allowed
so what am I going to do here is there a
way to trade the bishop somehow probably
not right if I go f5 this looks takes
takes f 44 oh it's not so bad maybe
my pieces are not that badly placed for
this kind of situation especially with
the queenside frozen yeah do I take or
not take Knight f6 exactly okay check
for Queen g6 and Queen g7 ultimately
okay maybe he wants to yeah but I have
to do something about this situation on
the long diagonal and that was that was
kind of stupid Queen g6g 3 is coming
right
I like to I really like to trade consume
this is annoying the screen on deform
okay okay not deform but I have most
things covered here like e6 and so on
it's not such not such a problem here 93
for night f one little trick maybe a
little trick here and there is Sir is it
loud I guess this is really working
right check okay once in a while you can
do with the cheap trick white exam yeah
it happens to all of us I think it was
about equal this position yeah it was
interesting that he that he allowed a
for is it's not so common that why does
that I'm basically for fading all ideas
on the queenside with before it's not
yeah not the end of the world but it's
not so common sometimes they fall porn
is a liability for black even hair like
attacked with this and this but at the
moment I'm having it very securely
protected bishop on d7 and so on and
here i prepared at five and a thought
that should be ok year five hi
interesting hmm yeah the comp is giving
f4 and that move would affirm probably
post more problems yeah without trading
on fi first obviously I cannot go if I
before so now I have to play with this
this kind of situation 97 oh this looks
good I mean good it looks like the move
to play but hmm
okay yeah the engine gives white 0.6 and
I have bad feeling about this white is
better equipped for this kind of open
combat here in the center with us this
big tension here queen is badly him I
don't know that was better i guess i
don't think i have any substantial issue
here this looks good but I it I played
one or two but stupid moves Queen f7 is
better than Queen g6 I guess okay it's
not a big deal or anything I was
thinking I'm okay here about equal comp
gives black a slight edge when I don't
don't don't buy it this is very equal
ish it's very difficult to do something
I have white for example puts the night
only three hmm can you do it now yeah
maybe you start with this I'm sorry
start with this kind of regrouping the
night only three is very nice blocking
this e porn it looks here so it's quite
nice it's very difficult for black to do
anything i can double on the g file but
it's not that it ever gets get this get
very much I mean you have the odds the
odds trick ah yeah I could have taken on
f4 actually did not see that move quite
needa this is made checkmate and this is
a pot hmm so the best is probably here
and then 92 or thurs the comps line huh
now I did not see the move at all I was
I was kind of thrilling with my little
night f1 trick and TM he fell into this
low trap yeah it's not not that obvious
a move maybe um okay um watched what is
it that you should do we are maybe a
step out of this then i can i can try to
push this I think it's really equal it's
difficult to open the position is the
problem yeah I hardly can ever play
anything on the queenside why the same
the center is blocked it is kind of
equal ish I believe simply because of
lack of progress
computer gives black quite a sizable
advantage but I'm not sure that it's I
mean this sometimes it's the K is in
this closed position the computer likes
one side because of a space or bishop
pair or things like that but it doesn't
really see a way forward let's say it
just says okay I'm good and it just
shuffles yeah it doesn't show any way to
really make progress and this could be
such a case I'm certainly okay but I
don't really have anything in particular
it's about equal okay well thanks for
watching